>> Dana: A CONTENTIOUS G7
SUMMIT.
CHINA HAS HAD AGREEMENTS WITH
WORLD LEADERS AND ALSO DEFENDING
HIS TRADE POLICIES EARLIER TODA
TODAY.
>> CAN I JUST CLARIFY SOMETHING
YOU SAID QUESTION MARK YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY --
LET ME DO THE CLARIFICATION AND
THEN I'LL GET TO THE QUESTION.
YOU TALKED ABOUT --
WHY WE REPEATING WHAT SOME
PEOPLE SEE IS A CLEAR LIE?
>> WAS ANNEXED DURING
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S TERM.
SPEAK OF THE BACK AND FORTH ON
THE CHANGING OF STATEMENTS FROM
YOURSELF SO THAT --
SPEAK I'M SORRY GOOD IT'S THE
WAY AND NEGOTIATE.
THIS HAS TO BE A DEAL THAT'S
BETTER FOR US AND IF IS NOT
BETTER, LET'S NOT DO BUSINESS
TOGETHER.
SPEECH IS BACK AT HOME, DIMOCK
HAS BEEN CRITICIZED FOR
ATTACKING DRUM ON THE ECONOMY
WHILE HE WAS IN FRANCE.
>> HE IS TOTALLY
HE'S DESTABILIZING THE ENTIRE
WORLD ECONOMY.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS NO PLAN FOR
THIS IS JUST CHAOS AND OUR TRADE
WAR BY TWEET IS HARMFUL TO THE
U.S. ECONOMY.
>> THE WAY THIS PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN USING TARIFFS, HE'S BEEN
USING THEM LIKE A MEAT CLEAVER.
MAYBE THE BETTER WHERE IT IS A
TWEAK LEVER.
>> THE CURRENT STRATEGY, I'M NOT
EVEN SURE YOU CAN CALL IT A
STRATEGY.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
BOTCHED THIS THING.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS FORCED TO
DEFEND HIMSELF.
A REPORT CLAIMING HE WAS USING
NUCLEAR BONDS TO PREVENT A
HURRICANE FROM THE U.S. CREATED
WE THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC.
YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON IT
ESCHENBACH >> I THINK PETE
AGREES, THEY LOVE THE IDEA OF
NUKING A HURRICANE.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING, OKAY, NONE
OF THIS STORY IS SURPRISING OR
ALARMING AT ALL.
TRUMP IS ALWAYS AN INQUISITIVE
OUT-OF-THE-BOX THINKER.
EVERY FIVE SECONDS HE'S ASKING A
WHAT IF TYPE OF QUESTION AND THE
MEDIA TURNS IT INTO A FRONT-PAGE
STORY AND HE IS LIKE I DIDN'T
MEAN IT.
I DIDN'T MEAN IT.
BUT IT'S JUST A QUESTION AND
SOMETIMES HIS COUNTERINTUITIVE
IDEAS WERE CREATED PEOPLE
DYNAMITE OIL FLYERS, RIGHT?
I DID SOME RESEARCH.
PEOPLE FIGHT FIRE WITH FIRE,
THEY ARE CALLED BACKFIRES.
ALSO, IT NEVER RAINS ON RUSSIAN
PARADES.
WHY'S THAT?
CLOUD SEEDING.
THEY INDUCE THE RAIN BEFORE THE
PARADE.
SO THESE CRAZY IDEAS HAD TO COME
FROM 70 WITH A BIG IDEA LIKE
LET'S BOMB THAT HURRICANE.
>> Dana: WHAT I THINK IS
ALARMING IS THAT SOMEBODY WROTE
THIS DOWN IN A MEETING IN A
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
MEETING AND GAVE IT TO THE MEDIA
BECAUSE THAT MAKES THEM FEEL
IMPORTANT LIKE THEY WERE TRYING
TO EMBARRASS THE PRESIDENT.
>> Charles: HE SHOULD BE PROUD
OF THAT IDEA.
>> Juan: SOMETIMES THOSE SHOW
KNOCKS ME OUT OF MY SEAT.
THE TWO OF YOU ARE SAYING THAT
YOU BELIEVE THAT HE DID SAY
THIS?
>> Charles: I DO.
I DO.
>> Dana: I WOULD --
AN OUTCOME OF THE PRESIDENT SAYS
IT'S FAKE NEWS AND THAT HE NEVER
SAID IT.
HE SAID HE NEVER SAID IT AND I
CAN IMAGINE THAT HE WOULD'VE
ASKED A QUESTION IN A NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL MEETING, SURE.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN --
I MEMBER WHAT AND 2008 AND THERE
WAS AN ASTEROID HEADED TOWARD
EARTH AND IT WAS LIKE WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO DO.
>> Pete: KNOCK IT OUT WITH A
HURRICANE.
THE BOMB CAUSES THE HURRICANE TO
GO TOWARDS THE ASTEROID.
>> Dana: WHICH THEN PROTECTS
THE NUCLEAR WEAPONS?
>> Pete: BREAKS INTO PIECES
AND DESTROYS THE REST OF ISIS.
>> Charles: I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD GOOGLE HOW DO YOU NUKE A
HURRICANE.
>> Juan: I THINK THEY SHOULD
NUKE MY HEAD BECAUSE IT'S
BEGINNING TO EXPLODE.
>> Charles: THIS WAS
FASCINATING TO WATCH FOR THIS
GUY IS THE AMERICAN BULL IN THE
EURO CHINA SHOP AND HE SAYS I
HAVE BIG IDEAS, AND PUTTING
AMERICA FIRST, YOU ARE ALL
GLOBALIST, I DON'T CARE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT CANADA,
FORMALLY OF U.K., FRANCE,
GERMANY, ITALY, MANY OF THEM ARE
FRONTALLY UNSERIOUS PEOPLE ABOUT
THE REAL PROBLEMS WE ARE FACING
IN THE WORLD.
I JUST WANT TO GO THERE AND TALK
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> Dana: THIS IS THE FOREIGN
MINISTER OF RON AND HE BASICALL
BASICALLY --
McCONE HAS HIM ON THE TABLE --
COAT BUT THE PHOTOGRAPH THAT
THEY LAKE IS AT A TABLE AND
THEY'RE ALL LAUGHING ABOUT IT
AND THIS GUY IS WITH A
GOVERNMENT THAT TERRORIZES
INNOCENT PEOPLE.
>> I LOVE THAT YOU POINTED TO ME
TO MAKE SURE THAT I KNOW WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M FOLLOWING.
BUT THE TRUTH IS THAT I AGREE.
I THINK IT REALLY DISRUPTED THE
WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS ENTIRE
MEETING HERE DO I THINK IT'S A
GOOD THING TO OPEN THE
DISCUSSIONS THERE AND THAT
McCONE IS TRYING TO FACILITATE
THIS CONVERSATION QUESTION
MARC SHORT.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT OUT OF
THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T BELIEVE IT WAS A GOOD
DEAL.
HE HAD HAD TO PUT FORTH WHAT HE
THINKS IS ANY CLEAR IDEA BUT I
DON'T THINK HE IS IN A RUSH TO
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS BUT HE
HAS SAID THAT HE IS OPEN TO IT
BUT HE'S NOT IN A RUSH BUT HE
REALLY WANTS TO RUN THE FIELD
A LITTLE BIT MORE BUT I DO THINK
MEDICATIONS GET PAID I DON'T
THINK THIS WEEKEND WAS A GOOD
TIME FOR THEM TO REALLY FOCUS ON
THAT.
>> Charles: LET ME FOLLOW-UP
HER LET ME FIRST SAY WITH
REGARDS TO NUKING A HURRICANE,
YOU HAVE BLOWN MY MIND.
I MEAN, YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE WOULD BE DAMAGE TO
HUMAN BEINGS FROM THE FALLOUT
FROM A NUCLEAR SLIPPAGE, YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT RIGHT?
THIS IS HOW YOU DO CLIMATE
CHANGE AS WELL.
THIS WAS A BAD WEEKEND FOR THE
PRESIDENT IN TERMS OF DEALING
WITH THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE, PETE,
NUMBER ONE ISSUE BUT WE'VE GOT A
TRADE WAR GOING ON WITH CHINA
THAT NEGATIVELY IS IMPACTING THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY.
>> Pete: IT WAS A GREAT WEEK
AND FOR HIM ON THAT.
>> Juan: DIDN'T GET ANY IDEA.
HE DIDN'T GET ANY ALLIES.
HE DIDN'T GET OUR ALLIES TO SAY
WE WILL JOIN YOU
MR. PRESIDENT AND PUT PRESSURE
ON THE CHINESE IN STEAD.
HE SKIPS THE MEETING ON CLIMATE
CHANGE -- GRACE THAT I WAS
GOING, BUT I WAS LATE.
NO, YOU ARE GOING FOR YOU JUST
GAVE UP MR. PRESIDENT.
SPEECH YOU DON'T McCONE DID
SAY THAT THE FRENCH POSITION WAS
TO AGREE ON THE INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY.
>> Juan: BUT IN OTHER WORDS,
IF YOU GET A DEAL, IF HE WAS
ABLE TO EXERT MORE PRESSURE BY
BRINGING ALLIES TO THE TABLE --
HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
I THINK HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
I DON'T THINK HE DEALT WITH THE
SITUATION IN TERMS OF THE
IRRADIANCE OR THE SYRIANS, A
SIDE WHICH CONTINUES TALK ABOUT
ISIS, ISIS IS GROWING BY OUR OWN
EYES.
YOU DON'T BLAME THE PRESIDENT.
>> Charles: I'M JUST GLAD HE
SAID THAT CHINA SHOWDOWN WAS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT ISSUE WE ARE
FACING ARE NOT CLIMATE CHANGE
BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT I THINK.
MOST PEOPLE AREN'T EVEN PLAYING
ON HIS LEVEL AND YET HE'S GOING
TO DO TOUGH THINGS.
TO PETE'S POINT, WHENEVER YOU
ARE IN AN EPISODE OF THE CHUMP
SHOW, NO MATTER HOW MANY NUMBER
OF VARIABLES THERE ARE, IT'S
ALWAYS TRUMP VERSUS X, Y, AND Z
WHERE THERE ARE HURRICANES OR
JOHN MARK OF THE MEDIA BUT NO
MATTER THE SIZE OF THE
VARIABLES, IT'S ALWAYS ONE TO
ONE.
IT'S HIM AND EVERYONE ELSE.
>> Juan: AND EVERYONE ELSE
WANTS RUSSIA AND THE G8.
>> Dana: HE MADE A COMMENT
ABOUT ATTENTION PEOPLE ARE
RUNNING WITH IT.
IT IS NOT SAYING TO LET THEM
BACK IN AND ATTACK.
I JUST SEE AT AGAIN THAT'S HIM